[Musique]
ma mère
voici le temps venu d'aller parier pour
nom salut nazi de revenus bunia
tu peux garder ton vin ce soir je boive
est mon chagrin at il est revenu
toi la servante toile à maria vaudrait
peut-être mieux changer nos dramatique
et
nu mes amis ne me laissait pas ce soir
je repars au combat où on dit mathilde
puisqu'au-delà mon coeur mon coeur ne
t'emballe pas c'est comme si tu ne
savais pas qu'en la matière est revenu
[Musique]
mon coeur arrête de répéter qu'elle est
plus belle qu'avant l'été la matière
pierre revenus mon corps arrête de
bringue balle et souviens toi que je
tâte déchiré la matière qui est revenu
mes amis ne me laissait pas non dites
moi dites moi qu'il ne faut pas maudite
mathilde que vit ce que tu fous là
et vous méme à rester tranquille c'est
un chien qui nous revient de la ville
mathilde est revenu et vous mes mains ne
frappez pas tout ça ne vous regarde pas
mathilde est revenue
et vous même à nos tombes les plus sourd
n'évoquant j'vous pleurer dessus
mathilde est revenu
vous vous même ne vous ouvrez pas vous
mais bras ne vous demandez pas ce hacker
et mathilde timide ce que sera la mère
arrête tes prières dont jacques
retournant vers m'attire mais revenu
uni importe nous du vin celui dénoncé
des festins matière de mes revenus
pour la servante toile à mariah va
tendre monde on me dit tu auras m'attire
mais revenu
amy ne comptait plus sur moi je crache
au ciel encore une fois n'appelle
mathilde puisque tu veux là
[Musique]